alors là actuellement et 3h20 du matin
on sort d'une petite nuit blanche passée
sur naruto et tomb raider alors il est
3h30 pardon et on doit être prêt pour
trois heures pour 4h contexte il arrive
d'entre nous quelle est mon caleçon qui
sèche à coups de ses cheveux ça
bonsoir 400
alors ouais
cette aventure percevoir
j'ai fait fondre le bout du sèche
cheveux en laissant dans lequel sont
l'objet les caleçons ça tue la mort à
faire bouillir l'eau des pâtes dans une
boule bio à passer plutôt pratique
parce que oui on se fait des pâtes à
3h30 on est des mecs comme ça
mais pastore c'est vraiment top
o des malades
on a fait trop peur j'étais fini je suis
fatigué [ __ ] plus grâce à se voiler
cern bois je veux monde est moins gros
donc on fait un peu n'est pas toi ça va
être prêt à adapter en dix minutes
d'extraits de vie attendant on reste
coiffé et peut-être se doucher aussi en
très très low speed histoire de paix est
trop moche comme pour la forme aussi je
vous ferai départ et 3h30 internautes et
si la vague et avec un short de bain
parce que je n'ai plus de qu'elles sont
évidemment l'élément principal
constituant élections la touche
nationale il oui quand il est chaud y
ait cette aventure est réellement
incroyable il faut bien actuellement
mais dernier épisode les experts squeeze
de hockey
tout les gens se sont habillés
à voir si franchement lorsque l le sou
ça doit être bon tac on sort la passoire
tellement plus tôt pourtant à
l'élaboration des pâtes etc sûrement
pour le patriotisme n'est pas sans
blague très subtil
bon allez hop ça s'appelle faire à temps
on va lui dire qu'elle à pointer avec ce
qui me peine d'attendre et critiquer
mais pas toc est allé faire je vous dis
déclarer ses sets sont rétablis ses mots
ok les pâtes sont crades gens avec les
pas de son break les cartons que tu veux
demander à google de venir manger c'est
près de 10 à manger tue avec brad
mais non c'est pas que d'autres et que
sa fille claude
non c'est à dire ouais écoute je suis
moi je suis moi je faisais des films les
méchants un petit peu possible
bon allez on bouffe partie et c'est
arrivé
nous allons actuellement taxées qu'en
penses tu en vitesse où j'ai touché un
peu religion alors vous avez loupé du
lourd
à savoir à savoir des grosses fermes bio
grâce donc ouais on est sorti du taxi
d'une heure et demie je me serais posé
on a dormi en boule en position foetale
sur un siège on est toujours avec madame
qui a pris on a pris ça comme un mot cas
c'est un mélange suis café de chocolat
se trouve tout à l'heure pour d'une baie
la mission actuelle
non
un prochain épisode nous arriveront
enfin dans les studios de rabbit
lesquels qui développe le jeu triel sur
pc au rendez vous on va donc découvrir
le jeu avec d'autres youtuber on va
jouer avec nous on va bien se marrer on
va pouvoir aussi interviewé du stade de
rugby et enfin visiteur peut les studios
à bientôt dans le prochain épisode